[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Daniel
est-ce que tu sens quelque chose
pour l'instant
dis-moi Daniel
avant moi tu as tué des mecs
femme qui rit complètement dans son lit
c'est pour ça que je t'aime aussi moi
pas trop rigoler
le premier donc je le connais non c'est
le deuxième que tu connais pour éviter
de me caresser
alors le deuxième tu peux pas me le dire
sur l'oreiller dans mon oreille
il y a trop de monde
c'était une image une expression c'est
d'oreiller tu sais dans un moment en
fait dans un moment de une fois un
moment d'extase en fait
que je lâche le morceau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour l'instant qui va arriver
pour me dire les choses tu me dis
d'accord et bien là ouais ça va ça va
bien